the Panama registered japanese-owned
cargo freighter Fremantle highway is a
floating furnace in the North Sea she's
been maneuvered out of the busy
international shipping lanes and is now
stationary off the Friesian island of
amaland
from where a plume of white smoke could
be seen in the distance
at the moment a small ship has been
attached which is not an ideal position
you cannot tow it but it can hold it in
its current position for as long as the
fire burns there is little to do but
spray her sides with water to reduce the
temperature in the hope of keeping the
ship stable
The Blaze is said to have spread quickly
in the early hours of Tuesday the cause
remains unclear the crew Abandoned Ship
some jumping for their lives into the
sea to be rescued by the Dutch Coast
Guard one crew member died while several
others suffered smoke-related injuries a
major concern out in the inky Blackness
of the North Sea is what happens if she
sinks the nearly 3 000 Cars Plus Fuel
and other cargo on board this giant
freighter are a risk to the ecologically
sensitive Friesian Islands just off the
Dutch Coast a UNESCO world heritage site
the area is known for its diversity of
Aquatic and terrestrial species
what is loose on that ship what can was
ashore can it lead to hazardous
substances on the island I'm just
thinking about things like that
the Coast Guard says Salvage experts are
working through a range of scenarios for
the stricken vessel warning the fire
could yet burn for days
Jonah Hall Al Jazeera on the Dutch Coast
foreign